hello everyone welcome to another
episode of play watch listen I'm Alanna
pierced
I am drawing bye I said joined joined by
awesome wintery Troy Baker and Mike
Bethel do you have a very interesting
topic that I wanted to talk about this
week I linked it to you guys do you guys
all read the doom it's on OST open
letter Mike did you not starting
back-and-forth the next five minutes to
complete the chants
I did want to touch on this because I
lost it's fine you're illiterate we need
that anyway it's a good article that
iron ran would write it was it was
excited to treatise it's very
interesting stuff and I think I think a
very good look into how the Internet can
get carried away with things so I did
ask you about it last week he wrote
Austin yeah I mean this is it was
written by actually oh it's literally
written by mati that's crazy
yeah Marty wrote it huh well well you
should you should set up what we're
talking about yes so yeah we touched on
it very minimally we did and I'm very
glad that we had a fair take more
information basically there was some
people who looked at some comparisons of
audio files from it was either some
tracks and doom eternal awesome traps
from doom 2016 and some from eternal and
sold that they were like very much
bricked which in theory means that the
audio is less of quality it's a very
simple way of putting that and someone
tweeted at macgowran who is credited as
creating the soundtrack for both of
those games does an incredible job very
popular I'm a huge fan of his work
brilliant compose the best in the
industry clearly Wow we know that that's
her that we know that that's her go-to
you know blast at full volume yeah which
is not because a lot of those songs
weren't even made for that soundtrack
they would just pulled into it but
anyway hey one that's the thing that's
this right law of Composers they put in
the work they really try to curate some
prefer it when they done it [ __ ] it I
prefer I prefer it whimper just go go
with the field that's real talent my
favorite soundtrack ever is advice I
have no disagreement with anything any
anyway yes so someone tweeted it may
Corden with those screenshot of those
audio files and was like what happened
to you and he said well I wouldn't have
done that that was also a DM which I was
never really sure if was real but this
makes it sound like it Israel way said
he won't be walking with its software
ever again so the community very quickly
turned on Bethesda and on Eid because
the assumption was that Mick Gordon as
the artist for some reason had been
mistreated to which Austin you brought
up the point last week of not
understanding why they would ever want
to hire someone like Mick Gordon to then
reduce the quality of his work it
doesn't really make any sense
why they would enter into that contract
and then give him well I don't know just
literally decreased the quality of his
work is the the best phrase I can think
of to describe what happened that it's
it's akin to this is a this is a strange
comparison to make but I think a
reasonable one there was this movie
called Mirror Mirror with Julia Roberts
that was kind of an updated take on the
Snow White story and it's really not a
great film what Lily Collins play Snow
White which is the best part of it
because she is flawless casting she just
is Snow White but it's very kind of
cheesy and it doesn't it's kind of it's
too kitty and yet not kitty enough and
it's it's sort of aspiring to the Disney
magic and and so they hire as part of
that aspiration they hire Alan Menken
[ __ ] 8-time Oscar winning King the
sound of Disney itself you know equal to
the Sherman Brothers and they hire high
school ask them a little bit right i
well brothers are overwhelmingly known
for basically three things the Jungle
Book Mary Poppins and then it's a small
world at Disneyland and did they do
wishing we should put a star to wish no
I'm blanking on the guy's name
I did it I did it oh I got Austin to
draw Blake and I think I've gotten Mike
to be oh I don't have that book back
there you found the you found the feel
like the week the missing brick in the
wall but all right please get it in case
oh yeah so Alan Menken you know I I
actually I agree with you Mike I think
that culturally he has surpassed them if
only just because the volume of of hits
is greater I don't think that any
individual hit is necessarily greater
but he's just done unfathomable amounts
of incredible like generation-defining
work anyway all that said Tarsem Singh
the director of this movie which is also
an interesting choice because he
directed like the cell which is where
this super crazy dark twisted movie and
and then he goes and does this Mirror
Mirror and but the thing that baffled me
was that they hired Alan Menken you know
the king of this and I was stressed a
new explosion into the same tint is your
background we went a bit doom 2016 yeah
try to be on brand you guys mm-hmm all
right forgive forgive the length of this
side note but the point is that they
hired Alan Menken is a very fine
composer of scores but for sure his
secret magic his superpower is his
songwriting and the best part was that
they go just take care of the score I
the director I'm going to write a song
for this film and I remember thinking
that was the most baffling choice I had
never seen in my life like you have you
have an eight-time oscar-winning
songwriter who is like arguably the most
sort of engrained into the conscious
alive of any songwriter certainly anyone
growing up in the late 80s early 90s and
it's like no I got this and that's that
was what struck me that's like with the
doom thing you go and you bring someone
on board
you know it's one thing one thing if he
was kind of like this journeyman style
you know I can I can throw some things
over the fence and just kind of give you
what you need and there was no kind of
solo personality but he obviously has
that in spades and so it I remember
thinking there's clearly more to this
story no one would invest this is a
major major triple-a game that's
spending gazillions of dollars and
especially after doom 2016 they realized
that the score like they approached the
music in the first one and conceptually
and creatively as though it was going to
be integral to the experience and then
that turned out to be validated and I
remember Romney actually was the one
that convinced me to play it because I
had played those games so much growing
up and then I was like it looks
essentially the same I don't know that I
need that again and Rahmi tweets this is
basically speed metal the video game
mm-hmm
and I say any the fusion of those was so
kind of perfectly balanced that I
thought all right you know what I'm
gonna go play and I totally loved it and
and I thought the score was utterly
inseparable and so I think knowing that
they had that alchemy payoff it was
built into the marketing and the
awareness of this one I mean they were
upfront advertising things like its
inclusion and collector's edition and
all that sort of stuff and making it a
big deal they released one trailer that
had a rap song over the top and people
could not stop making fun of it but my
logic was they probably did that for
audiences very mainstream audiences who
might be off-put by the idea of metal so
that was a marketing trailer for
everyone else not for you who know and
like the metal for everyone else because
it was I think it was the TV spot so I
get why that had to be done differently
for all the people who are like is it
what is this that's a guitar this but no
that's the same reasoning that goes into
we have to do a live-action trailer for
our game it's like because we want to go
mass appeal we're going very broad on
this and I remember sitting down across
from PR person for a publisher it
doesn't matter who and I said how many
users are across the consoles and
they're like
you know I I don't know what even knows
like just just ballpark it is like and
this is when the this current-gen it
just pretty much launched and they're
like I mean I don't know 10 million 12
million I was like cool if this game
sold 10 million copies would that be
considered a success she's like oh my
gosh yes it's like then why not just go
after those people as opposed to hey you
gamer who's never bought a console
before you should play this game now
hold on a second first you need to spend
500 bucks getting a console they need to
learn how that console works and then
you can I was like I've never understood
that whole notion it's just like make
this the game that everybody's [ __ ]
playing I'm like what are you doing so I
can't stop playing this game is like
what game is this is this game and let
that spread like that but if you if you
were able to sell five six million
copies that's like a huge success for
people and then they can go out and go
play the game that everybody's playing
that's what GTA was GTA sold [ __ ]
lights out numbers and people were like
why guess I'm gonna go buy a ps4 and
start yeah you have to be all that
culture moment yes but as far as going
you should do this thing you've never
done before for this thing it's like not
only is this 60 bucks it's like [ __ ] you
man I'm just gonna go do what I've
always done I've never understood that
and to me putting a relative track very
interesting things that happen in
videogame marketing but I always want to
be like won't know [ __ ] and it must suck
for some studios like for example
PlayStation right now is obviously
treating the lost of us plot to like
their their crown jewel but then like a
game like concrete genie even which came
out last year which was awesome didn't
get a lot of advertising or a lot of
marketing budget didn't sell well and
they're gonna be like well it didn't
sell well question it didn't you didn't
put all your goddamn marketing money
into it I always had this thing where
I'm like they put so much money into the
game that is definitely going to succeed
and so much less into a game like goes
to Tsushima and I get why they do that
it's because they can justify it they
could justify more of a marketing budget
for something that's selling more but at
the same time this is so common I feel
like a lot with Sony maybe a little bit
less though with Xbox is that they just
keep marketing the [ __ ] that
you already know everyone knows about
right hold on though but I mean like
ghosts the the marketing spend is
proportionate to the budget of the game
rights which I understand right but I'll
made I mean first party it's the budget
as Troy says but then with third parties
that there are different deals and of
course but like you look at like what
before Sony was this global thing right
before there was like there was there
was ski there was SC UK there was Sony
America and everybody had their own
different marketing things so if there
was a game that there's marketing spends
that were done in the UK for and and
Europe that were done for the Last of Us
part one that weren't done here and it's
because they had their own special
marketing things so it's it's a really
it's it's not you can difference in the
way FIFA is advertised depending on
where you are is crazy absolutely if
you're in Europe it's like the biggest
marketing that everyone that's on your
buses and on your billboards whereas
here we usually get like I imagine
cyberpunk will be all over buses for
whatever that's your bus game I feel
like I've seen a lot of us maybe even
advertised on a bus stop Mortal Kombat
was the most pervasive when it came out
that was the one that I saw every member
in this area yeah it was like really
what's funny is GTA 5 pushed and
BioShock Infinite slid into their
marketing so that's why everywhere you
saw outdoor advertisement billboards bus
stops everything with that for because
but it was because they had spent
however 250 million dollars on outdoor
advertising for GTA and people are like
we're putting company you've already
bought that spot we can't resell that
spot I guess we're gonna put BioShock
Infinite
so by take-two they still in theory
could just same come they'd already
spent the money it's like what you could
you could put up a picture of Terrence's
ass we don't give a [ __ ] but you're
still gonna spend that money and so
Bioshock would not have gotten that big
marketing push had GTA not slipped
interesting yeah well I mean Raskin kid
is like pushed and it's just like
I'm totally a tangent but it's just a
thing that always runs in my head where
I'm like does that studio walking on a
new IP that less people know about are
they like wish we got that marketing
budget but of course they're unproven
you can't get that marketing budget but
I just see I don't know if this is parts
of that analyse Joe has been responsible
for it so let's say that you had a
hundred and fifty million dollar ad buy
and that game concrete genie or whatever
didn't perform as well as it would have
they still are on the hook for that
money yeah it's it's there's no it's
like the record business nobody was like
oh he gave me a million dollar signing
bonus I'm like cool you now have a 1
million dollar debt you have to pay that
back and the publishers are not just
giving away free money they're like
congratulations and Mike please feel
free to correct me on this but it's like
we're gonna spend a hundred million
dollars on on advertising and the dev
goes hahahaha okay and you've done the
numbers to say that that's going to
equate to X amount of sales so that we
can recoup that it's like we're gonna be
fine because yeah there's a lot of
witchcraft and I'm gonna tiptoe very
carefully around some friends projects
but yeah I've heard that story in lots
of weird ways of like games indie games
have been you know massively promoted
and then that promotion wasn't
necessarily justified by the million you
don't get that money then that money's
been spent by your publisher or your
platform and and like the your split
never comes back
so is it is witchcraft there's a lot of
very small people who try and figure it
out but you never know and we've we've
always taken the approach uses you
suggested Troy at the start of kind of
we would much rather super engage with
Aneesh than try and go mega mainstream
with any of us
and that's I mean honestly that's also
realistic given the games we make as a
studio we're not making things they're
gonna be the 50 million player games
maybe one day but so far not so much but
that was the fortnight model two
fortnight was just like we're gonna play
to this base right here and then
Donalbain now yeah where they know every
why by night but that's when they're
like what if we did this this would be
pretty smart if we just did this one
thing and I don't think that you had
that the success of a game is not gonna
depend upon we've gotten so far away
from it
the gamer Isles is such an interesting
marketing one because the only way you
can really advertise them and it works
effectively which has worked for
virtually every single one is by putting
money into people to stream so they go
the influencer route which is exactly
what apex did for sure and they do that
because the battle royale strategy is
such it's even making those games is
such an interesting concept because they
are infinitely renewable content without
the actual developer having to put new
stuff in because the other players are
the ones that create the different
experiences so no matter what you can
stream about a ralph forever on the same
map without adding any new assets and
it's always going to provide limitless
content because of other people's so I
feel like paying to stream those games
you can do it forever and you can get a
ton of people on board who then want to
play with those streamers and yeah apex
apex is still paying just for streamers
just to have people play that game and
it came out last year February if you
have their number I feel like as well
with this stuff it's always worth saying
anyone who's watching this who's like an
indie developer who's just getting
started like these rules and these best
practices shift so quickly yeah like in
terms of what Alana's saying is super
true right now but like five years ago
was put ads on reddit it's the only
place you're gonna sell your game before
that was put put you know put money into
youtubers you know it's it's always
can't tell you how much my goddamn
industry changes every minute they're
like wow you're youtuber is number oh no
we need to be on Twitter just like being
in media and working for an editorial
team that's like if any size more than
five people is just someone at the top
being like I've decided this changes
every single month because some exec has
decided the strategy has changed and
you're like okay we don't care about
that anymore
got it all right it's it's nuts working
in a kind of the Oreos it so games are
kind of the opposite as we often say
again sorry has to be slower I would
imagine it's yeah it's much slow that's
the problem is we're off and you know if
you're releasing a game in our case we
release really we have a game out
usually once a year but like you know
proper game studios they may have like
four years between releases right so
with them often they're basing their
planning now on
worked or didn't work four years ago so
you have these kind of you can often be
just completely out of touch with where
the audience's or they need or what they
want but yeah it's a it's a weird one I
don't think there's ever any good
answers we're all just kind of guessing
and hoping for the best with a lot of
this stuff in the case of platform
holders doing deals with them to get
support at launch and all this kind of
stuff yeah Austin did this great set up
for this whole reddit post
I don't know how by the way I had time
to read it because I was just drawn
cover for a cover fire for you Mike that
was your time to read and you squandered
it by the same reason why you could
please switch and watch Clone Wars okay
I'm not gonna read this whole thing
because it is quite long but I'll leave
a link in the description on YouTube for
you guys if you want to read it but it
says basically at e3 last year we
announced that the OST would be included
with doom eternal collector's edition at
that point in time they didn't have Mike
on to contract for the OST and because
of ongoing issues receiving the music
they needed for the game they did not
want to add distraction at that time
it's worth it's worth noting by the way
that I you know every every composer is
entitled to kind of make their deal
structure however they want and in the
case of a game like doom that album is
probably presumed to be actually
commercially quite viable compared to
the average soundtrack album but
nonetheless the phrasing of that really
jumped out because it is not common for
soundtrack album contracts to be like
his insinuation is that it is it was
like tabled totally an unknown quantity
and that the score deal was essentially
all that they had on the table and
that's pretty unusual if they announce
OST before they had done the deal as
well
they announced it I read the robbery
yeah that's yeah they were gonna sell a
soundtrack that they didn't have the
rights to at e3 that is bold is the
polite word for that those bold mares
part of the collectors at
and yeah would really exciting announce
though I'm gonna be selling all of
Austin's music for everything he's ever
passed and future you don't figure it
out they also have like a verbal yeah
yeah but to his credit at least he owns
as like look yeah at that point time we
didn't have Mick under contract for the
OST and because of ongoing issues
receiving the music we need it for the
game did not want to add the distraction
at that time yeah cuz the game should be
priority and I appreciate that they have
that approach a lot in this then it
jumps to if every twenty-fourth Nick
reached out to communicate that he and
his team of five it's times the
agreement but there was a lot more work
involved than I anticipated a lot of
content to way through and while he was
making progress it was taking longer
than expected they gave him a six-week
extension rather than a full week
extension that he asked for and then he
would provide upwards of thirty tracks
and a runtime of over two hours and then
it goes into basically that they grew
increasingly concerned that he wasn't
going to be able to deliver the OST on
time they were having trouble hearing
back from him the product had not be
delivered and they had to deal with the
the legal issue that customers could
demand a full refund for a product if a
product is not delivered on or about its
announced availability date meaning that
they didn't deliver the OST on time but
that's the in theory could have gotten
sued for that that would be a massive
problem for them so they then spoke to
their lead audio designer to begin
watching or even if not sued it's
grounds for a refund on on a thing where
like it represents the smallest
percentage of the value of the thing
they bought but it's so it's like if I
paid a hundred bucks or thing for a
thing that includes the soundtrack and
they don't include that and I request a
refund
you know the the five dollar or maybe
ten dollar portion of the hundred bucks
has brought the whole hundred bucks down
yeah it's also just bad optics right
just looks about that office of the
leader thing yeah for sure
okay so Chad the lead audio designer
began to work on the inversions of the
tracks which is a back-up plan should
make not be able to deliver things on
time to do that
Chad needed to take all of the music as
Mick had to live it for the game edit
the pieces together and arrange those
tracks into a comprehensive OST and I
actually didn't know this I found this
real
interesting obviously Austin you would
know all about this but they say it is
important to understand that there's a
difference between music mix for
inclusion in the game and music mix for
inclusion in the OST several people have
noticed this noted this difference when
looking at the waveforms but have
misunderstood why there is a difference
when a trap looks brick dough like a
ball where the extreme highs and lows at
the dynamic range of clipped this is how
he received the music from mix for
inclusion in the game in fragments
pre-mixed and pre compressed by him
those music fragments he delivers then
go into audio system and a combine in
real time as you play through the game
so basically it wasn't that some Audio
designer decided to change mix tracks it
was that that was what they had received
for the game from him Mick did also say
you should have someone on your team
walk on this he basically signed off on
the idea that Chad would be allowed the
actual quotas
several days later Mick suggested that
he and Chad working on the backup
combine what each had been walking on to
come up with a more comprehensive
release so he had basically also
suggested that that should be a thing
and that's by the way I have the whole
notion of the mix being wildly different
from what's in the game versus what's on
the album both the mix and the Edit like
people I think assume that because a
soundtrack album breaks it into you know
10 20 30 or whatever tracks that that is
how it looks in the game that there's
like track 5 is the one that's playing
now right that's almost never the case
is especially on but it makes sense that
it's not especially we do a tunnel when
you know you you seem to hit up a climax
in a fight and the music is there with
you and then the fight ends and it dies
off perfectly it's like well yeah that's
that's programmed yeah exactly you have
to deliver a toolkit in the same way
that like a dialogue tree system in you
know a Dragon Age game will have all the
lines recorded individually because by
virtue of the choices that the player is
making its stitching together the
conversation from this grab bag of the
constituent parts that's honestly how a
lot of interactive scores work as well
it's like I have a cue that's broken
into like okay perfect case to use
journey as an example when you go
underground and you're in the kind of
door
cavernous midsection of the game it
breaks up into sequential rooms and like
you go into one room you explore you
maybe find a glyph then you move into
the next room and then move it and every
time you move into a room it triggers
like a transitional little non looping
what we call a one shot or stinger and
then it moves into a looping cue but
then some of them are even more nuanced
than that where like there's one room
where you're floating you have those
kind of what looked like giant kelp
cloth sort of trees in quotes and they
make you float and so I had the music
attached to the altitude of the player
so if you detach from one and let
yourself float all the way to the floor
which very few players do it strips away
about two-thirds of the instruments over
the course of that and then we'll add
them back in as you go back up because
the room is arranged vertically and it's
all obviously done in real time it's
it's essentially like real time re
mixing of the music so when you go to
make an album you have to make a
conscious decision like okay I have all
these ingredients you know I have the
elements that fade it in and out or
whatever based on the player's altitude
do I want to try to simulate that on the
album so that it almost sounds like I'm
listening to a play through you know
what do i what do I do with this and in
some games especially if the music's
super interactive you have to make
really subjective choices and in most
every one of my albums at least the
music that you hear is not only
different from what's in the game it's
actually not possible to trigger it that
way in game because for the sake of
making a better listening experience
I'll often do things are all put things
I'll just oppose things that weren't
ever juxtaposed in the game or I'll put
something first that later would come
second or whatever you just make these
subjective choices so everything that
they're describing about mix process is
completely normal and reasonable that's
the thing like you do you bust your ass
to get it over the line and in the game
and then you kind of start all over to
make an album especially care about the
quality and clearly he does I mean they
he and I did a panel together at GDC and
even just the caliber of his [ __ ]
slides I was like this
like he is he he's the real deal and so
it's like you know I can't comment on
why he was behind schedule my first
thought was he had something going on in
his likeness last year I was like yeah I
was absolutely point sir I was
professionally unreliable and from the
outside you could have been like there
was a day where we didn't hear from him
I'm like well from my perspective it was
the day that I fainted but like I didn't
get back to my boss that day but as
exhaustive as this is though and this
goes into such great detail don't you
feel that would be included don't you
feel that Mick would be like hey man I
want to apologize it he lists reasons
right heel is legal limitation on that
Troy if it's about it it's disclosing
personal information about it's personal
he says like I as a technical issues
this has been more more of a challenge
and I thought the scope of it was
different I first of all maybe Mick
never let on what was going I did that
well I had a project that almost ruined
a really valuable relationship of mine
because I was not transparent about the
[ __ ] that I was dealing with and I was
going through some essentially the
hardest period of my life I've ever
endured and I and I was not upfront
about it and so all they knew was I was
consistently behind schedule and they
were like I we hope there's a score in
our game right but counterpoint
counterpoint to that would you have then
gone out to Twitter and criticized and
said I would have done it that way
that's not I didn't have anything to do
with that you know see that tweet I
understand why he did that I understand
why he would be like well I was not the
one who did that because like you know
somehow sometimes maybe a fun house
video that I edited it and produced that
it's clear that I added and produced is
titled in a certain way but someone
would be like why did you title it that
number like why I didn't title it that
but that's not me criticizing the other
person for the way that they did it
that's just me clarifying and being like
well I did not do that that way but
that's odd I was like I get why he's
doing that it was just like I can't tell
you why that happened IGN that happened
all the time so I wanna be like why did
this get written Emily I'm not even
anything to do with that department I
didn't do it it's so hard to ascertain
tone from text I I get that although he
does appear to be
very dispassionate overall it does feel
like he's trying to be very even and
fair who is Marty or Marty Marty yes III
see this being very factional III have
to go in just a minute but I do want to
say this and I had a conversation this
morning about this what with who invited
you have other conversations I was
special
I don't feel feel I'm using that word
this was necessary nor do I think it was
beneficial I feel that the reddit post
the reddit post doesn't matter this is
the point of the podcast it doesn't
matter and there's somebody that I had
conversation with this morning that was
like I wish that people had actually
been more public and said hey there's
here's the truth
but there's so in in this exhaustive
treatise that I think marty was
incredibly this was methodical it was it
was very intentional and it was very
like you said dispassionate and it was
honest but it wasn't
he was factual there so he's not like
but inherently it's still airing dirty
laundry that we don't need to know about
I feel like this could have been shrunk
down and go hey as a publisher or as a
developer there are things that are the
inner workings that you don't you don't
need to be privy to or that we don't
feel is necessary for you to understand
we stand behind this and that's all that
matters to make a statement of a
position rather than well then on this
date he said this so this actually
confirms what we were doing that's why I
look at it and go what's pissing me off
right now is the fact that X happens and
it's like okay then just let it stop
like here's what I wish would happen for
a school shooting I wish that if there
was a school shooting the news would
come on ago there was a school shooting
at X school people have lost lives the
shooter has either been captured or
incapacitated in some way and that's all
we're gonna [ __ ]
talk about it we're not gonna say his
name nor we can talk about the victims
door we gonna send a reporter there and
we're gonna have helicopters flying
around the school to show you the mass
layout because that is the problem the
problem isn't that this [ __ ] happens the
problem is that we will not shut the
[ __ ] up talking about it so that we can
respect the people that are truly
impacted about this and mass shootings
are concerned definitely agree but you
need to not glorify them we should not
glorify that anyway but this is none of
her business I think why this happened
and the reason that I completely
understand it is because I feel like
I've been in this position is because
Chad was being abused and sent death
threats so because he was being sent
death threats because of what Mick was
saying I think Monty says somewhere in
this post he was like I felt like I had
to do something it wasn't fair that he
was being treated like this that he was
being treated like a bad guy but that it
comes forward and says we have a stance
is a lot going on behind the scenes
people's gonna be like [ __ ] you how dare
you just treat us like that it just took
people it was you know yeah but people
are doing [ __ ] you regardless as what
I'm saying so well and and to that point
Troy the thing that blew my mind I think
more than anything reading that letter
cuz I you know I can be very sympathetic
to both sides of that and for sure like
there's probably a lot that was omitted
and it's you know and it's [ __ ] hard
to make a game especially a game of that
scope and right stuff gets you know
frayed and strained but the thing that
fascinated me more than anything was the
comments where the on the reddit post of
people that were like you know wow turns
out Mick is such an unprofessional
douchebag and [ __ ] that guy you know
what I mean and then the next one down
would be like [ __ ] you Marty way to just
throw him under the bus and own none of
it yourself and a lot a lot of like wow
you read the same words the same text
yeah and came away with diametrically
opposite vitriol the Internet truly what
a what a what a little lab like funny
half of concept of human psychology yeah
when I was reading the comments I was
like these are a lot more reasonable and
uh I saw were but it depends I just read
it's just it's too hard to have and I do
have to go I would it be respectful of
my wife's time of course I
look the fact that we can discuss this
to me is the most important thing about
it my thing is this there were people
that may put that posted comments about
the leaks and they were articles and
they were like okay so here's what I
found out and you guys need others like
nobody needs to know anything what you
need to know is that the game comes out
June 19th and that you can play the game
and experience that and make up your own
mind then the same thing with this if
you don't like the soundtrack you don't
like the soundtrack nothing that we're
going to tell you and this is gonna sway
that people are gonna make up their
minds before they do anything or before
before they actually experience it so my
thing about this was I love that he did
this I just don't I don't feel like it
changed anything I think all it did was
was make more people informed to support
their notion they already had going in
he's certainly doing it to defend Chet
which I understand I get I get that
perspective I think that coming from the
content creator side of things in my
head it is always best to be as
transparent with people as possible
because then you have all the pieces of
the picture and and if something is
controversial it's gonna get carried
away with no matter what and people are
gonna blow a proportion what happened
like it can get really messy but you
though to quote you though never explain
never complain and I that I've really
held on to that it's like all right look
I'm gonna tell you what's up once and
then I'll let you guys discuss it and
beyond that yeah I'm not gonna complain
about it I'm not gonna explain it yeah
sure you guys are awesome thank you for
letting me to be part of this
conversation on this I know see you next
week bye guys
there's a thing that feels we had to
mention without the inclusion of Troy
Baker but I've gotten a bunch of
criticism for not talking about the last
of us leaks and people have assumed that
I'd I'm not doing it because I'm friends
with Troy they're like that's really
shitty of you but I was like as a
journalist what value would I do anyone
by spreading that thing they were like
mmm are you not talking about it cuz
your friends betray are you not talking
about it cuz you don't want to review
copy no see I'm not talking about it
because there's literally no value a
journalist can provide in any way by
talking about something that is already
completely out there the only value I
could provide is if I figured out who
leaked it and how am I gonna do that but
otherwise there's just no public service
at all
I would get views for it but how would I
be actually helping anyone other than to
spread something that negatively impacts
both the audience and the studio whose
just know yeah there are there are other
stories around Naughty Dog there are
other discussions to be had and
professional course about like the work
staff game itself when it comes out you
know all this stuff but yeah I don't
really the leaks themselves aren't
really a story right unless you unless
you want to be spoiled on the game
experience there's just no value for me
to talk about it's also like I haven't
been spoiled for and I don't want to be
so if I make content about unfortunately
I've tried talking about it too much and
cuz I'm like please don't spoil it for
me but I just it's a weird I've gotten a
lot of criticism for that and it's like
that's just there's just no service a
journalist can give you for stuff like
this but then you know how strange is it
just separately from that that you would
be criticized for not talking about
something like like there's an
entitlement to your thoughts on any
subject at all never mind what it is
well everything yeah which is maybe
because I do expect you to and then
thinking uh interesting that she didn't
mention X versus going what the [ __ ]
Alana is this because of like as if that
that's a that is an odd one last 24
hours of people being now because you're
friends of Troy was like that's
absolutely not even slightly related to
why I won't talk about this and you're
not even friends with him yeah he's very
aloof he he basically I mean he doesn't
really like it now that he's gone this
is listen after dark not even a friend
really but I think I'm gonna bring it
but Roy's not our friend really that's
all that would be can you imagine what
he sees that pop over these YouTube
subscriptions the se proof that he's not
our friend he'll never see it but the
but to bring it back to the dim thing
like I think there is a hunger for
narrative there's a hunger for stories
people want an interesting gossipy story
right so like I think that's a very
negative story if you done this is like
a thing that I
not can that's why I can understand the
instinct of putting something out like
the same I don't know that I resent so
hard to write this [ __ ] like I don't
know that I would have done it exactly
this way but like a very good example I
have of just you know people wanting
drama is someone left IGN and because I
was close to that person and he left
without a lot of information people
assumed based on literally nothing he
sexually assaulted Ilana not sure
didn't happen that's still that comment
still comes back to me all the time
didn't happen and I can reply to people
over and over and over again and be like
this isn't true this isn't true this
isn't true this did not happen but
people will always be like I think he's
actually like the stories always it's
because the story's more interesting to
them I guess than nothing like
conspiracy theories because they don't
have a story and the reason for that is
because like he would be the one who had
to would have to tell the story of why
yeah it just doesn't make sense for
anyone else to do that so all I ever do
is go was not sexually assaulted stop
saying this what the [ __ ] but they kept
doing it over and over and over again
it's literally just based on the fact
that we were friends so like I know very
very well that if you want transparent
with audiences about stuff even when you
are they'll assume things are completely
false so I get why this was posted I get
why it was needed to be posted hot air
fills a vacuum I've also had to of like
at IGN given Statesmen I gave some
statements that I didn't even
necessarily agree with because I had to
read the the words that are in front of
me written by an exec about things that
happened while I was walking there and
some of it's like if you try to treat
audiences especially where I think the
video game community is concerned like
they are deserving of just a press
release it doesn't work you can't just
give nothing I can also understand the
argument for not saying anything at all
like there's definitely like there are
times where we've made that decision not
about anything serious but when you know
that there's nothing that you can add to
a conversation like that's happening in
your community and you just saw
basically stabbed and it sucks as
obviously you want to defend yourself or
or have a conversation especially if
you're right also if you're wrong in
fairness that's
like you do you do sometimes as a like
as a public company as a not also you
know public company in the financial
sense but like is a public facing
company sometimes yeah you do have to
decide not to be in the conversation
which utterly sucks but yes case I think
it I can see where it comes from I can
see why they wanted to kind of set the
record straight as they saw it and kind
of share that side of the story but also
I can totally relate to you know sitting
waiting for someone to deliver something
and knowing that there are five of the
deadlines that rely on them delivering
the thing they have to deliver yeah
don't be a jerk about it because then as
you said they may have a personal life
or whatever but yeah I can it's I think
just for what it's worth as a on that
note when I first read it it was heart I
felt like he was being so calm and
even-handed that I had a hard time
seeing it as I had a hard time seeing it
as him throwing him under the bus but I
do think that there is there would have
been credence to the approach of having
this unified front more like what Troy
said and basically saying you know dear
Doom community this was not Needle
malice probably yeah I like to walk
through it into kind of I there is an
airing of dirty laundry that I can I can
see to it I can I can see that yeah it
reminds me there's a story of a famous
Leonard Bernstein one of the great
composers and conductors famously gave a
concert once of one of the Brahms piano
concertos with like this super famous
and and famously eccentric pianists
named Glenn Gould who was like a
brilliant crazy person and and he wanted
to take the piece at such a slow speed
that Bernstein basically felt like this
is wrong like I know this piece of music
and we're basically not doing service to
what I'm convinced the composer wanted
but he also felt when you come to see a
concert and there's a famous soloist
listed Glenn Gould plays the Brahms
I think first piano can
certo you're there for that person and
the conductor or whatever secondarily
like if you see yo-yo ma or Joshua Bell
their name is the headliner and so
Bernstein came out and did something
that conductors almost never ever do and
maybe never had done prior to this he
came out and said you're about to see
something very very unusual it's worth
noting that I completely disagree with
this interpretation but I also think
it's my duty to honor the wishes of the
soloist who I respect that you're here
to see I remember when I heard that I
thought wow but he took and still to
this day half a century later enormous
[ __ ] for that because they thought in
the spirit of the Smarty thing he
basically was throwing him preemptively
under the bus and trying to wash his
hands of his partner's decisions and I
found myself remembering that story
reading through this or I thought you
know I don't think Marty or Edie is
doing the wrong thing here but they
maybe are going a little into the weeds
on the story that only raises more
questions it only just prolongs it and
in that sense I have a hard time finding
fault with Joy's reaction no I know and
that's where I think he's right is this
thing would be dead by now we wouldn't
be talking about it if that reddit post
didn't exist probably right that would
be the conversation would have moved on
we probably would be talking about it
because we would be looking at the
interesting side of it but like I feel
like the conversation in general I mean
yeah part of what I wanted to talk about
today is that PR is really hot like it's
really not easy and I think a lot of
people will be like well why didn't they
just do this and I especially know this
from IGN being such a big company and
people are so critical of IGN you could
say why don't they just do this and
there's always a million reasons why you
can't just do something and a lot of
it's a lot of people jump to conclusions
like I've been things at IGN that I was
100% honest about and I'll be like well
she's not talking about it because she's
under legal contract and it's like
there's no legal contract I'm just
telling you the truth but it's it's just
very it's very complicated it's really
it's really difficult to do to jump back
to this a little bit just just to finish
the story off basically it says on the
day the music was true from Mick I asked
what we could expect from him he
indicated he was still finishing a
number of things but it would be no less
than 12 tracks in about 60 minutes music
then I think he needed some more time
because he had tech issues after
listening to the nine
he'd delivered I wrote him and I didn't
think those tracks would meet the
expectation of doom Olmec fans there was
only one track with the type of heavy
combat music people would expect and
mostly others were ambient in nature
which is a very strange choice
he again suggested if more heavy trucks
I needed much easier to mix for what
it's worth true so yeah I mean all the
stuff related to chat again is is in
bold and that's why I feel like mati
wrote this because he wanted to defend
someone I think I understand that very
very well because the only thing that
really makes me very very angry is if
someone is mistreating someone that I
care about that's the only thing that
ever makes me go this isn't [ __ ] fair
I'll get very pissed off like I could
see myself doing this to be like this is
not fair porchat funny that his name is
Chad and the Chad is a meme that we all
make fun of Chad publicly all the time
anyway
Chad's all over the world we're sorry
about that if I tell someone named Karen
in the story as well the thing for me
and this is the best name drop lemon to
achieve on this episode to me childish
Chad's to hell ski and if all the people
in the world you definitely shouldn't
take the piss out of okay destroy anyone
who insults I think that's mostly it
yeah on 19 on April 19th we released the
OST to see iana's some fans noticed that
the wave forms with different etc etc
and that's why Mick said he didn't mix
those and wouldn't have done that which
to be fair he didn't but you know he
also didn't specify that he suggested
that did it or anything like that I
don't really want to get into the
personal aspects of it or our guesses
for what they were feeling any more than
we already have I'd prefer to stay on
the industry level of this do either of
you know much about outside of like them
being in a contract what happens if
someone is late to deliver something for
a game and it needs to publish what
happens if you don't deliver something
on time or an artist doesn't deliver
something on time what do you do well
I've been so for me I've never been that
completely close to the wire I've
definitely had to like I've had
milestones coming later for me I am
incredibly conservative with a de time
estimate I give anyone that isn't me
like when Austin was working on John
wick I trust Austin I love Austin
Austin's a professional
I never gave Austin a real date of the
actual deadline I actually needed
anything from him by because I always
will put in buffer after buffer just to
make sure that like if something does
happen if if if Austin was hit by
lightning we'd have time to deal with
that problem because unfortunately do
have to kind of plan for that here it
sounds like those deadlines were a
little bit tighter which I'm sure in
bigger productions that's much more
common but yeah so I'm I've never had
that I've had people be late with stuff
and I have had very awkward
conversations because yeah there is a
point where you have to kind of talk to
people and figure that out but it's
never been mean it's just like hey so
we've we've missed this up one thing
that games development in general has
gotten much better at and by no means
are we perfect at it which is why crunch
still exists but we've gone better at
estimating tasks and an estimating how
to structure our development process
anyone who works in tech is gonna you
know know about sprints know about scrum
know about the processes where you
actually make stuff in a way that
everyone is kind of simultaneously
accountable but also listen to in terms
of how long jobs are gonna take so I
feel like in most cases in game
development the jobs take so long you're
making a game for so long but if
someone's slipping behind you know about
it you can kind of adjust based on that
either you hire someone else to help
them or you change what they're making I
don't tend to fire people but I know
that's another solution that other
people use but it's it's it's it's yeah
you you usually just have like a
heart-to-heart about it and kind of
figure it out but I mean even though
firing someone isn't necessarily a
solution when it's it really is a mess
you're losing all of that knowledge yeah
you're losing the 50% of the job they've
already done yet hotheads exist in the
industry but ya be know you don't want
that you want to work through to a
solution unscathed change games require
so many people to have done everything
you can't just like if an artist doesn't
do something on time you can't just make
the odd
unless you're also an artist but if you
don't have that skill that's not
something that you can just pick up
basically right yeah like like for for
you to see let's use doom as an example
for you to see a specific
to see a kakko demon fly through the
environment and attack you that's 20 to
30 people's work at some point in that
process from the concept artist and the
designer at the start to the the artists
who put the model together animated it
coded it iterated on it ran the play
test to find out if that was fun or not
like everything is so interconnected
that yeah it's it's tricky and and there
are I mean a company in the size of mine
even has like a project manager you know
something called Rachel who literally
she puts together all of this her only
job I say only job it's a massive job
but her only job her focus is just
making sure that everyone's stuff hits
at the right moment so it feeds into the
hole so yeah one person up River
like having an issue some things are
easier than others music honestly is one
of those things where music is kind of
separated off tangentially enough but
there's a bit more fluidity you know if
we were closer we think we don't think
it'd break systems like music no isn't
like if if your game depends on physics
simulations and and you know your
engineers who are working on physics
like screw up or all clock out early you
know you know what I mean like they'll
they all are on the same car accident or
something that that will completely take
the game offline you know music is where
for better or worse we're much more
easily replaced or we are it's much more
easy to deal with delays or if someone
has to bail on a project or gets fired
you know it's it's it's kind of like a
parallel production as opposed to a you
know a root of the tree but even then it
can still be intimidating like if you're
going towards like an e3 demo and you
need a piece of music for sure you know
it's not a case that you know I'm using
Austin Austin with Boston's awesome and
I just read a review that said that your
music was the best thing about Johnny
cakes that's cool we don't reviews is
like bullet point 3 music but the I feel
about that I never that goal is never
for the music to be the best part
oh Michael I'm being kind there were
lots of good things yeah there's lots of
you might have thought Mike did
everything else wrong
exactly
bullet point three oh that was so chic
um but anyway my point is like you know
if if we were running up towards like an
e3 deadline and Austin wasn't delivering
the audio it's not just it's not that he
gives me a wave file and I copy paste it
into the game there's obviously a lot of
work that comes after that delivery that
you have to kind of just in terms of
this I know Chad's job essentially is
described in this in this post you've
got an audio person who's got to put
that stuff together put all about
triggering and all the stuff about like
making it so that when a boss enters the
music shifts that requires I think on I
mean on John wick correct me if I'm
wrong I'll see you were working with our
sound guy you're working with a coder
you there were a couple of people even
on the indie projects that were hand in
what he made after he made it on a
triple a game I can only imagine that
those numbers go up so yeah it's tricky
it's tricky but usually yes you try and
build in enough buffer that you can like
cuz cuz [ __ ] happens right like people
have things happen in their life you
have to if your game is gonna hit
serious trouble if one person gets sick
or gets busy with something then you've
got bigger problems you need to but yeah
it's it's I wouldn't I wouldn't comment
on a specific project but yeah it can be
it can be dangerous we've we've gone
close to the line on missing deadlines
before yeah but that's always a I've
always considered in our case that was a
failure of me as a as a producer and as
a manager to kind of let it get that
close to the wire and to your question
though a lot of like what would you do
if you were a game director or executive
producer or something and I feel like I
feel like there's no answer to that I
feel like they especially on well like
you either delay you either just aren't
just ship late or you ship incomplete
which you know depending on the feature
is more possible than than other
features like if it's record of the game
not so possible if it's some fringe
detail like if the UI was never finished
or something like that you know some
games just simply don't have any money
left over and they're like we got to hit
the green button sorry and so you know
it's they're gonna have to make that
judgment call but obviously a well as
Mike just said a well
old game a well scoped and produced
project is gonna have those buffers
built-in because as you start to flirt
with the line the feeling i I've never
I've like I said I had a few projects
during a really dark period of my life
that I got closer than I would ever care
to then I then I I wish I wish I weren't
admitting to how close I came to to to
really dropping the ball I'm grateful to
say that I didn't and also that those
teams
despite their anxiety which was well
deserved I was not making it easy for
them they were also there for me to say
like what can we do to facilitate this
happening you know they were not being
standoffish and saying well you're
[ __ ] us over here it was more like
let's work together to get to a solution
but I do have in the back of my mind
that thought of if not if all that had
failed there was this question of we
have no idea what we're going to do like
there some things you you plan so well
for their success that there is no real
turnkey plan for their failure you just
you would have to improvise in the case
of music again as Mike said between
bringing in another composer to patch
the holes or even licensing library
music you know like there are solutions
that will get you fast over the finish
line if you're really up against the
wall I've never seen that in practice I
don't even know of that happening I
can't even think of that happening to a
friend of mine like where or colleague
or somewhere they just literally it just
it just literally failed people have
always if you're once you reach a
certain level of the industry I've just
never heard of somebody just completely
and utterly dropping the ball like that
is so reputational that you would like
that's the thing in both in both in
terms of absolutely in terms of people
work who work for them own studios like
we're not gonna go into it but like
between the three of us we definitely an
Troy I know Troy I'll have opinions on
this where he doesn't watch this video
as we've established he's not a
subscriber or Fred but he but like there
are studios that are known for treating
people they work with not so well and
there are people who are known to be
talented
you know that person's a little
unreliable what I will say though is
that's not necessarily a deal-breaker
like you might know that someone's
unreliable but they might be that good
that you're like okay we're gonna bring
in that unreliable person but we're
gonna give them crazy amount of
additional time we're going to assume
that they might but even then like even
then reputation is everything in this
industry and we're me and Austin both
like we wouldn't be getting the gigs we
get if there if we let people down and
there's a certain amount of honesty that
pushes on both of us that we we have to
treat people well because it would get
around like if I if I treated people who
worked for me shittily that would be
known within weeks if Austin was really
messing someone over with soundtrack he
would struggle to get his next gig and I
think there's an I think that as he says
like once you're a little bit more
established in the games industry you're
very aware that your reputation is your
biggest asset right well it's that way
in my my side of the industry even
though you would think that people who
are interested in working in games media
are numerous and everyone who isn't it
is very replaceable reputation doesn't
matter that much people can get drunk
and miss appointments
nothing happens like they can they can
do really dumb things frequently and
absolutely nothing bad happens it's kind
of nuts and like the thing that happened
to me makes this really interesting to
me as like as a producer especially when
I was working on TV if someone else
dropped the bowl which I felt like
happened all the time I would just do
the thing so because I I just working in
meteor especially as a producer in media
things aren't that technically
complicated so like I know how to
publish something I know how to edit
something I know how to do it all it's
not my job but if we were coming up to a
deadline and someone wasn't going to
meet it I would just be like [ __ ] I'll
do it and then I would do it so like the
idea of having to depend on a team of
people with skills that I cannot use
myself as a backup for gives me anxiety
the thought of that being like I just
they would just have to all do it
correctly is terrifying but maybe
because I have worked with a lot of
people in games me know that I would
kind of consider to be unreliable some
of the time and that's but that's the
thing I think as well that plays into
the whole not necessarily wanting any of
this we probably like again like I'm
sure me and Austin would have story
and you doing when we tell these stories
about things going wrong we don't name
people right like we we all have had
working relationships that have been
Tafel something's gone wrong or
sometimes let us down like those things
always happen the difference is you're
never going to hear me publicly talk
about any of those things because I know
reputationally it's in my best interest
not to tell if I go on Twitter into a
five tweet thread about this particular
company or this person I'm broadcasting
to other future kind of colleagues hey
if you work with Mike and you piss him
off then he will that's there so it's
service if someone has done something
that's bad enough that everyone needs to
know about it I would say it I have
occasionally had people who someone
other people have worked with that I
have like privately message them had
been like just so you're aware you're a
friend or whatever here's the thing that
you should know about that person I
should I should definitely clarify for
the sake of this show when I talk about
people being bad I'm definitely not
talking about actual abusive awful
people
you can [ __ ] off and professionally that
I'm talking about people who let us down
in a work sense like abusive people can
[ __ ] off and yeah I will absolutely
happily endorse that but the yeah
industry-wide worldwide really the Buse
of people can [ __ ] off just generally
yeah let's let's be bold let's be bold
let's make that statement I think like
they all have webisodes ago we were like
[ __ ] code today [ __ ] abusive people
should remember the comedian a stand-up
Demetri Martin has a whole bit about
that of like the phrase never throw
stones and glass houses and he's like
how about irrespective of housing
situation let's just not throw stones
this shindig move in general yeah
stoning outdated stop doing it
making statements here I feel like this
thing actually was a calming influence
come back please come back it really
does it just relaxes you right yes like
I said I will leave a link to that right
up post in the description below it's
definitely an interesting one to read is
the best way for me to put that thank
you both for joining me and we will
you all next week my hey